you
[Music]
welcome man well it's great having you
here I hope you enjoyed yourself thank
you it has been great first of all it's
a wonderful playground and secondly you
have these very interesting people I one
after the other is it's like if a kind
of person one can stay for like 25 years
and not get tired I know yeah so so you
know just think as I followed your the
work that you're well known for for
which you received the Turing award a
few years back and I personally didn't
know about your deep interest in brains
and minds I think are some recent
discussion we had so I think the rest of
it was a kind of slide I got pushed in
the wrong direction I'm finally doing
what I really want to do tell me a bit
more about the back when you mentioned
this really cool story during your talk
yesterday or I say fun story how I got
into this yeah don't be with your father
and you know his his request to you yeah
yeah
so the beginning was what when I was a
young kid I was and I learned English in
the Bronx when I was about to go into
the first grade well your first language
my first language is German for four
years then my parents came to this
country nobody like to hear German
because they were at war Germany so they
switched the Spanish I always spoke the
language that nobody understood until
until I went into grade school I
remember see I knew I had to learn
English I was going to go to first grade
I saw two women at in the corner
speaking to each other and I sort of
stood there with my back to them so they
wouldn't know I'm spying and I remember
listening to them and telling myself
exactly this I will never learn this
language they speak much too fast for me
the interesting thing about this is I've
been remembering that in English and it
couldn't have anything that's funny you
know sort of an internal translation
over the years since I didn't speak
English I didn't do that very that
on school and by the time I said to the
second grade the teacher I was pretty
dumb the teacher said you know to my
mother mother parents teachers
conference you know he may be able to
get through high school but he'll never
get to college and so this bothered me
because I said I should share with you
that was shared with keep you big
straight very or fourth great
limitations yeah yes yes it was before
the before the fourth grade so you know
second grade and so the teacher had
advised my mother to start speaking
English to me and I'm and my mother told
her I don't speak English and she just
responded well what do you think you're
talking to me and so when my mother's
which I learned English I remember ooh
switching that when I switched the
Spanish for four or five years why sir
finish I was born in Venezuela okay
where they all speak Spanish so my first
language German would they speak Spanish
I didn't understand and I remember when
my mother switched the Spanish in the
Bronx that one month later after she had
switched she discovered she realized her
shot that I had forgotten my German and
I could see her at the window thing
window how do you say window Fenster
because I so I pride myself in being
able to learn languages but I'm even
better at forgetting them that's great
look you keeps your mind flexible so
knowing that you were you might finish
high school and then go off to do some
something that was probably not
intellectual the rest of your life how
did you take to this this is the
prognosis from the teacher and your and
being passed on by your parents yeah so
I really wanted to be able to think
better that was and I was having trouble
with memory couldn't remember stuff so
my I asked my father
how can I think better how can I
memorize how can I memorize and he said
well you just do it which didn't help me
at all and and then after I pestered him
enough he suggested you know if you
understood how the brain works
you could that would help you to become
smarter and I consider that the most
wonderful advice that one can give a kid
a kid in the first second grade is just
right to get a focus for his life that
was just wonderful for me it's not the
interests thing that we never really
think that we don't have an owner's
manual on this incredible machine and we
expect it to just somehow fly-by-wire by
learning as we go when there's probably
a lot we could do with reflection
introspection guidance understanding how
to learn better had I had a challenge
ourselves intellectually why a math
problem that seems really hard it
shouldn't be a blocker to be a question
as to why I can't understand it and then
the tide learn how to think about it
absolutely ya know do you think that
that question from your father frames
your the curiosity you have minded
brains are you already getting curious
about it on your own well that was the
beginning but certainly I'm lucky that
we moved a lot so I can I have my
memories place your letter milestones of
my day yeah well and so between the
third and fifth grades I had moved we
had moved out of the Bronx I was in
Westchester County in New York and so I
can remember I would go to the library
and take out books on on the brain and I
was a little embarrassed to be because
other kids were taking up black beauties
of it and you kind of find that owner's
manual sometimes younger than you so I I
would open the book to the back think so
the librarian from Stanford so she
wouldn't see what it was I was taking
out so when you went to
MIT to do EE the idea of you actually
finding your way into the lab which Lee
is mind blowing of McCulloch and Pitt's
because I read that paper years ago I
said oh my god these people are the
first people to write down and abstract
what a neuron is as a mathematical unit
and then build circuits if normal neuron
and you actually work with these people
wonderful people
these were wonderful can't tell you how
Marvin Minsky was my thesis advisor but
Warren McCulloch was really my mentor
it's fabulous
Walter Pitts whose sidekick who really
taught me a lot Walt Walter for example
told me that anything you want to know
you can get from books now that's not
what that's an overstatement because the
things we want to know that you cannot
get from and then that's sort of thing
you do research for but the truth is
there's a lot you can get from books and
Walter the librarian take out books and
every so often the librarian would would
tell him you got to bring those books
back so he'd get a wheelbarrow literally
a wheelbarrow to be able to bring them
sounds like the overdue fines would be
quite expensive maybe a wheelbarrow full
of dollars and coins so so um and this
to describe this way I mean people
listening to this maybe don't have the
same admiration for McCulloch and Pitt's
that I have since being you know quite
young and reading about brains and minds
myself but what they did with their
paper 1943 yeah yeah this wonderful
paper that introduced the formal neuron
and the form only run with its inputs
and they basically proved that you have
to have inhibition not just that with
excitation a lot alone you could not
have they were trying to what they were
doing this theorem was that you could
use these formal neurons to create
construct a Turing machine nowadays we
know you can do that but at that time
this was the paper that showed it and in
the process of showing this they they
saw that you know you can't do very much
unless these formal neurons get both
excited and inhibited and so they told
the other neurophysiologists there is
inhibition in the brain and the nervous
yellow gist all the time said no we've
never seen it and they said it's got to
be there and now we know it's not only
there but it's a major major player and
for sure it's a major player yes very
interesting and so they rounded after he
insisted that the USA rather I'm doing
drink during the on the whatchamacallit
offense that during that timeframe in
that timeframe that's fabulous so for
the first in the goldfish retina they
found neuron which had this very thick
fiber coming in and it was an inhibitor
whatever that neuron I was doing when
this thing fired it stopped that neuron
cold very interesting and so until you
experience in that lab that you thinking
more deeply but the mathematics that
might be important in in brains and
minds soldiers do you think how you went
from this interest which clearly is now
that I understand your background and
what you've presented yesterday at your
distinguished lecture how that frames a
number of things that you did including
the work on recursion and someone that
behind this was interesting some
questions about minds yes I did think
that recursion recursive function theory
and logic were the kinds of mathematics
I needed in order to build this manual
of how the brain works in order to
understand and they describe a little
bit about the work on recursion that you
did maybe in a broad sense of about
though the intent and the results there
I'll describe one thing out interesting
which is not mine it's this proof that a
Turing machine it's a very simple
computer can start it on a blank tape
can actually print out its own
description on the tape it's called the
recursion theorem and it it shows you
exactly the proof shows you how to build
the Turing machine so that
Prince had its own description and this
is part of machines that can then self
reproduce you first ran out of the
description and then you go to a
constructor or sees the description and
then builds it and what does that imply
about about systems that could reflect
about their own thinking processes
through the same logics yeah so it does
sound sound very related I mean for for
one thing it means that Turing machine
can print out its own description and
then modify it and then follow these new
instructions which that tells you why I
got interested in recursive function
theory I would not do it that way I
understand that and also speaking about
doing it that way let's talk a little
bit about this pursuit of of some
formalism that could describe a model of
conscious experience or consciousness of
course when you mentioned that word you
end up navigating a space where you
passed philosophers and people are doing
with with with imprecise terms and not
making good progress the sign degrees
yeah it's crazy out there right people
think I'm actually nuts what what am i
doing so I have a friend a Gong Bao ash
who's 96 years old still quite active
and he absolutely refuses to believe
that a machine could actually feel the
sort of feelings he has when he fell you
know and he's in love for when he hears
music doesn't he believe that we make
incredible existence proofs of Homo
sapiens yes so it's interesting I have
yeah how come you know how human beings
think that they are closest to God that
they are the center of the universe and
I really always hated that I terribly
hated that and I was so happy that there
were things like Copernicus saying well
the earth is not at the center the Sun
is and then you know and there were many
examples like that where we find that
we're not as so different from the other
animals
and you know there was a time when when
life seemed to be completely different
from non-life that it was it was seemed
impossible with envy with a special
spirit right how can you go from F
equals MA to a life spirit impossible
yet it works right I mean again it works
and I think we're at that same point now
where people say okay so we can get life
but feeling emotion that we can't get
that we'll never get that
well maybe before we go there let's
let's just do it discuss though I think
it's important to make this
discrimination with this distinction we
and will get what I have more deeply
into just some high-level descriptions
because we don't have it we don't have a
white board hearings we have one we can
use but slides okay
right but we'll talk more about the
particular model that you you
linguistically will describe the model
you have in mind that's that's that's
exciting you and Lenore right now your
wife and your colleague and Avram your
colleagues on this front in this pursuit
well we just asked the question is
stepping back a bit so and I just clear
up some confusion which might even help
with with folks understanding of what it
is that you're doing and there is still
it's still this distinction between
coming up with definition and a
computational architecture and even
algorithms that might run on it that you
would call a model of consciousness
machine based model of consciousness
that may even read on what human brains
are doing distinguishing that from the
coming up with some deeper understanding
or tuition about the nature of
subjective experiences in qualia and I
think last night we were chatting you
did make that distinction you said look
look I'm not gonna I can't answer those
questions yet sand which is to say more
about that part because I want to make
honors first distinguish those two
things and then move ahead on there
sure okay sure so I'm a theoretical
computer scientist and so so let me make
the point about how this theoretical
computer science works it it works by
creating models and making definitions
and whether these models are correct or
not depends on the results you get and
whether they agree so for example this
is M
definition of zero knowledge proof where
you can convince somebody that a theorem
is true in such a way that they can't
turn around and convince anybody else
it's a beautiful definition of zero
knowledge due to okay so anyway so there
is this beautiful definition and it's
sound is even the term zero now sort of
suggests that if I give you a zero
knowledge proof that you're getting no
information other than the truth of the
theorem this is the way it's described
you get no information but the truth
it's not true for example when I if I
give you a zero knowledge proof you
learn something about the actual length
of the proof you also learned that I
know the proof because you can't give us
your announce booth without knowing this
you know a lot there's a lots of
additional information the point is that
a good definition can actually give you
an understanding of what's going on and
so the way the way I'm doing it here is
and this is the way theoretical computer
scientists work as I make a model and I
make or we Leonor and and I we make this
model and then we define this is what
consciousness is this is what a chunk is
this is what short-term memory is and
people may or may not agree but their
illusion is between those structures and
those those portions of definition and
then how the mechanism works and what
you believe personally is likely going
on in human minds at some level
absolutely I mean when I define
conscious we are consciously aware of
what's in working memory we're not aware
of anything else that's going on that in
the model I can define that precisely
this is what we're conscious of whether
this actually corresponds to what's
going on in the brain and most people
say that's not the way it works okay
again just back to my earlier comments
last question and distinction you could
carry this too deeply and it might even
be a great explanation for certain
aspects of what's going on in human
minds or even a nice blueprint for what
evolution discovered when it came up
with with with vertebrate Minds and
almost a pians but ones that are now
interacting across this table but but
but but there's still a distinction
there between going from that to some
workable understandable explanation of
why that would cause the feeling the
feelings or called the actual
experiences that pains and pleasures
themselves of being here and I wonder
just maybe keep it off the table not
because we're not gonna get to that
probably today or maybe you we won't get
to that as a community for decades or
forever that particular distinction well
I certainly hope we will get to it
within my lifetime which is right now no
more than 10 more years so I come on
you're gonna go further than that but
whatever I point is I really I'd lose
think we can get to what that feeling is
about but right now that's not part of
your in any way part of the model itself
in terms of even even the the current
local goals of laying out the model and
being precise about what short-term
memory is for example versus long-term
well laying out the model allows me to
define allows us to define things like
consciousness the terms and and we tried
to give use this now to actually find
out what it is it generates the feelings
there are many possible feelings my
particular interest is the feeling of
pain that
again before you get into that one I
want to dive into the do you have a deep
dive with you right now
on these topics and how it works but
even just a prefetch a bit here even the
pain thing that we talked about that
you'll be talking about it's not
necessarily the subjective quality that
we have as humans of pain that's a
different it might be relating but I'm
sure why that's happening in terms of
how that's generated or you know why
this part of our universe that the
mechanism seems to be able to do that
see whereas I think that once we have
once we've proven the theorems about how
this works
anything derive conclude can suggest
experiments that maybe our the model
predict predictions you know it's like
McCulloch predicting that then there
must be in addition in the brain I want
to make some predictions
which come out of the model which
suggests that this these notions of the
feelings of pain are correct so so um
this idea of there being a big massive
sea of impressive and broad subconscious
reasoning processes that we don't have a
direct access to and then some notion of
a smaller conscious process that somehow
the subconscious pops ideas and I and
and solutions up into to some sort of a
threshold in process has been around
broadly for awhile and I was one that I
I reflect about and I seen in writings
for years and I know they've been
influential in your own thinking who
would some of the people that have that
have worked on this outside of might say
theoretical computer science yeah so the
main first person I found out about with
Bernie bars but Stan - Amy has a
wonderful describe because it's go back
to the describe bars model and Daini
something it's kind of global theater
for example yes a bars model is this
global theater that think of theater in
which there's an actor on the stage
usually just one actor maybe a couple
mainly one actor and there is this
audience processors these the audience
of people who have specialties each
person in that audience has their own
special interests one of them really
loves chess and knows about tennis and
if anybody body on the stage asks a
question about like what move to make
next or anything like that this chess
program would look at it and it's really
some other other psychologists like John
Henderson for example have the act are
kind of like right so yeah so they they
have their own models and again I'm
trying to I think the difference is so
John Anderson says the brain is very
complicated the model cannot be simple
and we say Lenore and I say the
mathematics can only deal with very
simple ideas very simple constructs we
need a very simple model so in this way
it's different from the others I want
the simplest model back and start to
make definitions and prove theorems
about them so let's let's let's dive
into it now so we let's take the global
generics of a globally this this global
theater model and as this list now carry
forward into into computer science sure
maybe you want an application like for
example what would this you know how I
have an iPhone here and if I want to if
I want to look up this person that I met
this morning here her name is Ajay Ajay
Kumar Ajay Kumar right if I want to look
her up a month from now how will I find
it will I find her but googling for Ajay
probably he won't find it because it's
not under Ajay her name is spelled ECE
so - do I look and in the calendar
do I do I look in to my phonebook where
will I find her so in this model of
consciousness the way this would work is
you asked the question and all of these
apps that you have here the calendar the
Google or the Bing they all all of these
different
I hear the question and try to answer it
wouldn't that be nice you don't know
where the information is but you ask the
question and they all work on it and the
one that has the answer pops it up to
you and I love that idea I hate having
to search around for through all of
these absalom they could be doing this
once they there's some notion in your
model of we'll call it the you know the
stage the executive the short-term
memory as you refer to it and somehow it
a gimmick requests down that old
broadcast it's in broadcast right and
can make a request and you know they
won't always be answered the way you
want I have this pain and could you
please turn that pain off and you know
for some reason the the processors
refused to do that but what's her name
the it's very like the processor will
respond it's also what it so just got
you though the basic if you get it just
draw the architecture some basic ideas
of how this all works you have the stage
on top you have all of these individual
processors at the bottom and whatever is
on the stage is broadcast down to those
processors so that they all are paying
attention to what's on the stage the
stage presumably has very little
information how do they get back T and
then I hear from and then those
processors have to send their
information back up but of course the
the stage is very small only one or two
of those processors can get up there and
so some sort of they have to decide
amongst themselves which is the most
important information to get up there
and so we thought about this question of
how to do this what kind of
communication can they do to decide and
we realized it can't be very complicated
it's the information has to go up there
very fast so we decided that really it's
going to be no more than comparing two
numbers there's
one processor has some information which
has certain weight plus three and
another processor is information that
values is plus five so only the plus the
one was plus five goes up one level
rather than the plus three as so it's
just a simple comparison of numbers and
then there's the question of course of
well where do these numbers come from in
the first place and basically you can
say that like for example is pain that
the the the pain processor for the the
pain in my shoulder well the pain
processor can see how many nerve fibres
are firing nociceptors or firings how
fast they're firing and it chooses a
weight based on that kind of information
this can be this is true for all of the
processors there are ways for them to
measure and some measurements are too
optimistic pushing too hard to get up
there some measurements are too
pessimistic and the nice thing is we
discovered that our son Abram had
exactly this kind of a model and we had
written a paper called this the sleeping
experts that's all these processors down
below what a great way to solve problems
just had a kid to do it for you yes and
we are and we fortunately have that as
fact so his algorithm basically is
telling you how you how you compare
these how you are able to reduce or
raise the weights of these processors so
that they are essentially their weights
are optimally chosen and question is
there's several areas of your science
where this kind of thing is done in the
area of search retrieval we have a graph
with weights and the idea of you know
figuring out sort of what's a good
ranking function that would bring back
the right results given a query not that
far off from some of these concepts they
know I don't think this is far off at
all they're the only thing that Fargo
office said I'm going to try very hard
to be able to get to what's causing the
agony in pain what's causing the
suffering in pain
well III want to be able to order or the
pleasure the joy I want to get at the
quality I want to get at the heart from
yeah III do I am concerned that we'll be
making that leap will be tough even from
a great and it's intuitively pleasing
architectural solution that's just me
specifying some some sense that well it
might be difficult I hear you
so I would love to make it to find that
link to to do that leap with you so I
you know Leonor looks especially a joy
which is a very hard problem
I look at pain which i think is very
math imagine aid in heaven it's it's
really wonderful yes it's so but so I
look at pain and the there are many
explanations for why we have this
feeling of pain but one of them is that
when you have really serious pain you
cannot think about anything else
whatever it is you want to think about
you cannot if it's really extreme pain
you are killed as far as problem-solving
general problem solving real problems
always yeah and one of the things that
sort of makes me think maybe the I'm on
the right track is the fact that this is
the most anti-darwinian
notion you can believe imagine I mean
Here I am something has fallen on my
foot I'm on the extreme pain I really
need to get rid of it and I can't even
think of how to do it because I'm in so
much pain so we discussed yesterday I
don't many interpretation of that even
though it's kind of sad which is that
the the solution for Darwinian ISM was
to get rid of that human being out of
the tribe immediately having to lay on
the ground that everyone else run away
sorry it makes for explanation for this
but go ahead though yeah so but so so
here's here's a point if we can
understand that there there's something
we might be able to do you know
now and doctors want to know how much
pain you're in they have this set of ten
phases and from the happy face to the
one that's crying and they say where's
your pain and this is the best that they
can do right now I mean they can try to
use fMRI and other methods but this is
actually the way they do it the best
they have and the the pro doctors have a
problem somebody comes to end with that
shoulder pain and they don't know is
this person really in pain and really
should get those pills or is it that he
wants to get pills to sell on the street
and I think we might be able to come up
with a if we understand this well enough
we might be able to come up with a
solution for the physician how to tell
whether that person is how much pain
that person really feels and part of
that solution we feel will come from the
fact that if it's very serious pain you
can't think that clearly the less pain
the more clearly you can think and we
might be able to use that to create a
test something related topic what do you
think about people that say there's
really no such thing as consciousness
it's just the way machines that have
these abilities happen to to to feel to
perceive and you can't have these
abilities without it feeling like like
this to be one of these machines it's
just a definitional thing and we make a
big deal out of something that's just
the magic of being a powerful into
intellect yeah yeah so the wonderful
thing about this mathematical model is I
can define consciousness this is what's
conscious and nothing else is and I want
to prove theorems about that and it's
great maybe it's not what you consider
your conscious that's okay this is my
definition and this is what the theorems
are about so you know many people that
watch this this fireside chat are
younger folks who are thinking about
their career or even mid-career folks
we're thinking about maybe a change of
career I put topics they look at with
what they're thinking about I'm just
impressed that you know you stuck with
your early curiosities your whole life
you
when it was wasn't clear that that's
what you're working on well winning the
Turing award for you stuck with this
passion and interest about about about
brains and mine unless that had much
choice I mean that was what I'm
passionate about
I don't feel like there was much choice
I had to work on it I see it work on
other things but some but some people
don't don't believe they have the
flexibility or the ability to stick with
their main curiosity interest so I know
you stuck with it and you have no
choices actually I left it and I came
back and I watched why did you leave and
come back well in part because we really
couldn't start to look at how the brain
works until fMRI came on the scene so
even when I met McCulloch and Pitt's
that was 1963 I wasn't allowed to think
about consciousness we did had no way to
get into the brain find out how it's
working many people saving today and
even if I'm alright not really it's not
really getting isn't that much further
with our model of Colorado so pretty
yeah I'm not getting to consciousness
that's right but what I get in a sense
it's more for you since for you're
getting to be emeritus it's like okay I
want to really now the study it does
help you know first of all getting
tenure help I can do something that's a
little bit nuts and you know I'm now 80
years old that helps a lot just go for
it you might as well go for it there's
nothing they can't do me any damage I
mean I might as well find out so there's
a little bit of caution earlier in life
in the code it has to be after when you
know my father told me if you understood
the brain and you know he pushed for it
yet when I told him and this was the
fifth grade that I decided I was going
to become an anthropologist connections
to the brain my father stood up at the
table I remember and said you will not
be an anthropologist
anthropologists are professors
professors can't make a living you will
not be an anthropologist Wow Wow
interesting let me let me let me let me
end by asking you this question let's
say even in our lifetimes we get to the
bottom of things and we can verifiably
build a conscious computer that has some
of the or many of the consciousness
attributes of conscious we see we
understand to be part of being a
vertebrate creature homo sapien what
will that mean to our self conception to
the world to our sense for computer
science is what people are looking for
so you know this problem came up at one
time with chess you know computers
couldn't play chess what would it mean I
was asked if computers could play chess
what would that mean to our conception
of ourselves you know people are playing
chess all the time even though they're
easily beatable by the machines and yeah
yeah that's the hello and now we have
now we have some chess players that play
with machines against each other yes
yeah and new games as complimentary
computing the excitons yeah and look
football is very is a game that we like
to play you can build a robot that would
beat any football players but there's
something about conscious experience I
think that it's at the root of this this
deep curiosity and sense of the magic of
being that points up or sideways or down
towards spirits and and powers beyond
science
I guess it's just I think my sense is
that that's what's going on over there
over the centuries it's it's based in
the magic of what it is just to feel
like a human yeah so that is what people
don't believe that really I can get to
the basis to solve the hard problem
because that's beyond science and my
response is well so far there were all
sorts of things that were beyond science
that turned out to be scientifically
stuff solvable and
but in some ways just saying it was
there may have been an initial shock or
reaction but after a few weeks back to
normal again and yes you know we
understand that now I think I think
despite the fact that almost everybody
thinks I'm crazy and that this cannot
possibly be I do think that we will get
the solution and the and that this will
be very popular for us you know
something I agree with you thanks for
being here thank you very it appreciate
it